und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend als Putin vor über einem
Jahr sein Krieg begann soll er noch
geglaubt haben er werde im Handumdrehen
Kiew einnehmen heute versichert sein
Büro dass der Präsident bei einem
Drohnenangriff unverletzt geblieben sei
auf Videos sieht man Rauchwolken über
dem Kreml was auch immer hinter dieser
Attacke steckt ob es Ukrainer waren oder
Russen ob es ein echter Angriff war oder
ein Fake den der Kreml selbst inszeniert
hat in jedem Fall bleibt der Eindruck
dass es für Putin zunehmend schwieriger
wird sich als erfolgreicher kriegser
darzustellen der große Führer des großen
Imperiums wird auf seinem Boden in
seinem Palast attackiert nach Stärke
sieht das jedenfalls nicht aus Sebastian
ihn Bericht
in den Abendnachrichten des ersten
russischen Staatsfernsehens ist die
Topmeldung des Tages Terrorangriff auf
den krimel die Botschaft ist klar
Russland wird angegriffen
auf den russischen Präsidenten am
Vorabend des siegesages der Krämer sieht
es als erwiesen an das ukrainische
Nationalisten in der Nacht versucht
haben mit Hilfe von Drohnen das
Territorium des Kreml anzugreifen
doch was die Abendnachrichten nicht
zeigen sind diese Bilder eine Drohne im
Herzen Moskaus über den Dächern des
Kreml dann eine Explosion es ist unklar
wer diese Aufnahmen gemacht hat doch sie
scheinen der Staatsführung nicht zu
gefallen unklar auch wie zwei Drohnen so
nah an den Kreml fliegen konnten und
erst im letzten Moment abgeschossen
werden der Präsident jedenfalls sei laut
Kreml unverletzt und werde seine Arbeit
wie gewohnt fortsetzen
die russische Seite behält sich das
Recht vor antwortmaßnahmen dort und dann
zu ergreifen wo und wann sie es für
notwendige achtet
es ist bereits der dritte größere
Vorfall auf russischen Boden binnen
weniger Stunden heute morgen ging ein Öl
Depot in Gras und da in Flammen auf und
gestern Abend entgleiste bei brillants
gentzug mit Versorgungsgütern wegen
einer Explosion beide Male Beschuldigte
Russland ukrainische Saboteure
während am Nachmittag aus der Ukraine
unter anderem aus reson erneut
Raketenangriffe mit mehreren Toten
gemeldet werden dementierte ukrainische
Präsident selinski heute für die
Drohnenangriffe verantwortlich zu sein
er sagt dies während eines
überraschenden Besuchs in Finnland
national Fitness news we don't attack
wir greifen wieder Putin noch Moskau an
wir kämpfen auf unserem Territorium wir
verteidigen unsere Regionen und Städte
und so ist nach wie vor völlig unklar
wer verantwortlich ist für den
mutmaßlichen Angriff zweier Drohnen auf
den Kreml
Amar Salah von der Universität der
Bundeswehr in München ist uns
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr Professor
Marsala
schönen guten Abend sie wissen natürlich
auch nicht wer es war aber wonach sieht
das Ganze denn für Sie aus
das ist schwer einzuschätzen weil
sozusagen alle Optionen Sinn und keinen
Sinn machen also eine Force Flack
Attacken der russischen Regierung selber
zeigt eigentlich nur wie schwach die
russische Regierung ist dass sie jetzt
diese Bilder eines brennenden Senats in
in Moskau braucht um ihren Krieg zu
rechtfertigen wenn es Ukrainer waren
oder sozusagen Anti Kreml Gruppen in
Russland dann war das natürlich ein
massives Versagen des russischen
Militärs und des russischen
Geheimdienstes also die
Luftverteidigung in Moskau ist
anscheinend seit Matthias Rust auf dem
Roten Platz gelandet ist 1987 hat sich
nicht verbessert bei nah fliegenden und
tiefliegenden Objekten
das ist insofern eigentlich eine
peinliche Aktion wir haben es eben in
dem Bericht auch gehört im
Staatsfernsehen werden diese Bilder gar
nicht erst gezeigt
ja es ist eine peinliche Aktion es ist
auffällig dass diese Bilder erst nach 12
Stunden gezeigt werden weil dieser
Attacken fanden ja in der Nacht statt
wir haben die Bilder erst seit ein paar
Stunden es ist auffällig dass sozusagen
es mittlerweile Videos gibt die aus 12
verschiedenen Kamerapositionen diese
Attacke zeigen also da passt ganz viel
einfach nicht zusammen und deutet sehr
viel einfach darauf hin dass hier auch
ein massives Versagen der russischen
Politik vorher herrscht egal wer es war
ob sozusagen Ukrainer waren Anti
russische Gruppen oder ob es der Kreml
selbst war Präsident selenski der
ukrainische Präsident hat ja gesagt er
vermutet dass man damit das russische
Volk quasi zusammenschweißen will und
Soldaten die russischen mehr motivieren
um noch mehr sich mobilisieren zu lassen
oder an die Front zu gehen könnte da was
dran sein
das könnte in der Tat ein Motiv gewesen
sein wenn es der Kreml selber war es
offenbart aber natürlich auch die
Schwäche des Krems mit Blick auf diesen
Krieg dass man jetzt solche Bilder
braucht um die Kriegsmoral in der
russischen Bevölkerung hochzuhalten
könnte dahinter ja auch eventuell noch
die Hoffnung stecken dass man den Westen
und Ukraine spaltet also silensky hat ja
auch heute sofort betont haben es eben
gehört also wir greifen nicht auf
russischen Territorium an das ist der
gewissermaßen so dass agreement zwischen
den westlichen Unterstützern und Kiew
für da keine roten Linien zu
überschreiten
naja es ist aber so dass die Ukraine ja
schon des öfteren auf russischen
Territorium natürlich nicht so weit in
Russland selber militärische Ziele
angegriffen hat also von daher glaube
ich dass ich hier der Westen nicht
spalten lassen würde da Völkerrechtler
es ist zwar umstritten aber der
erfolgreicher durchaus argumentieren
dass der Kreml ein legitimes Ziel ist
weil natürlich aus dem Kreml diese
militärischen Operation auch
mitgesteuert werden ich glaube was man
sagen muss was auszuschließen ist
angesichts dieser zwei Drohnen ist dass
das eine gezielte Attacke auf putin war
also dazu hätte dann die Ukraine oder
andere Kräfte Informationen gebraucht wo
sich Putin genau aufhält im Kremmen und
ich glaube nicht dass er sozusagen unter
der Dachkuppel schläft sondern eher in
sehr stark gesicherten Räumen wenn er
sich im Kremmel aufhält deswegen würde
ich diese Interpretation ausschließen
und gab es ja in den letzten Stunden in
den letzten Tagen immer wieder Angriffe
sie sagten das gerade dann fliegt ein
Treibstoffdepot in die Luft oder dann
entgleist ein russischer frachtzug
könnten das schon die Vorboten der von
allen erwarteten ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive sein
ja es ähnelt sehr der Situation im Juni
letzten Jahres wo die Ukraine versucht
haben massiv sozusagen russische
Nachschubwege russische Logistik zu
zerstören und das was man sozusagen das
Schlachtfeld zu Formen betrieben haben
um eine offensive vorzubereiten und von
daher interpretiere ich diesen
entleisten Zug und diese Raffinerie
Anschläge die wir in den letzten Tagen
erlebt haben genau in diese gleiche
Richtung also man versucht sozusagen
diese Offensive gezielter vorzubereiten
russische Truppen von Nachschub
abzuschneiden danke schön für das
Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
dass die italienische Mafia genau
genommen die kalabrische auch in
Deutschland höchst aktiv ist das wurde
vielen wohl erst mit den Norden in
Duisburg bewusst sechs Menschen wurden
damals vor einem italienischen
Restaurant erschossen eine Fehde
zwischen zwei rivalisierenden Familien
so offensichtliche Blut Taten hat es
seitdem nicht mehr gegeben die Sache
geriet in Vergessenheit was aber nicht
heißt dass die Mafia hierzulande weniger
aktiv geworden ist im Gegenteil
allerdings wurde jetzt auch der Staat
mal wieder aktiv bei den Ratschen heute
morgen waren allein in Deutschland über
1000 Polizisten beteiligt in einer
großangelegten gemeinsamen Operationen
mehrerer europäischer Länder Benjamin
der Zugriff erfolgt am frühen Morgen
schwer bewaffnet stürmen wie hier
Spezialeinheiten in Italien die
Wohnungen der Mafia-Organisation
drangeta gefunden werden Waffen Drogen
und jede Menge Geld
in Deutschland werden insgesamt in fünf
bundesländernratien durchgeführt
Nordrhein-Westfalen Bayern Thüringen
Rheinland-Pfalz und dem Saarland
international ist es einer der größten
gemeinsamen Schläge im Kampf gegen die
Mafia das Problem glaube ich der Mafia
Strukturen ist dass sie teils sehr
subtil Arbeiten nicht offen kriminell
sind dass man es eben nicht entdeckt
dass es im Geheimen stattfindet und das
ist aber dennoch den
Strafverfolgungsbehörden heute so eine
erfolgreicher schlaggelung ist das ist
wirklich ein gutes Zeichen vor allem
geht es um Kokainhandel aus Süd und
Mittelamerika gut 23 Tonnen werden
sichergestellt die Drogen wurden nach
Europa gebracht dort verkauft und das
illegal verdiente Geld gewaschen durch
den Kauf von Restaurants Immobilien
Eisdielen wir durften feststellen dass
Restaurants und Eiscafés
von drangeta Betrieben durchaus neben
der Geldwäsche eine andere Aufgabe haben
nämlich die Aufgabe ein strategischer
Stützpunkt zu sein wir besuchen diese
Kriminellen in ihren Hinterzimmern holen
Sie aus Ihrem Parallelwelten und geben
Ihnen eine neue vergitterte bleibe
jahrelang waren die Mitglieder der
italienischen Mafia sehr vorsichtig
gewesen hatten nie Handys benutzt
Gespräche immer persönlich und geheim
geführt Corona und die Ausgangssperren
machten das unmöglich mit sogenannten
krypto-handys versuchte die Mafia von
dort an ihre Deals abzuwickeln und
trotzdem weiter geheim zu halten die
Polizei knackt aber die Krypto Handys
kommt so an die Information die jetzt zu
den Aktien führten in München wurde
tatsächlich eines dieser eines der
Haupttäter festgestellt was für die
italienischen Kollegen ein großer
Schritt in den Ermittlung war
wenn es auch eine internationale Aktion
war so führen doch alle Spuren
letztendlich nach San Luca das kleine
kalabrische Bergdorf mit gerade mal
3.400 Einwohner
romantisch liegt es da und ist doch
schon länger bekannt als die Heimat der
dran geht da
bei den berühmten Mafia Morden in
Duisburg kamen 2007 sowohl der Täter als
auch alle Opfer aus San Luca es war ein
Krieg zweier Mafia-Familien aus Italien
in Deutschland
inwieweit die Razzien dieser Nacht mit
über 130 Festnahmen wirklich nachhaltig
die Mafia Strukturen zerschlagen können
bleibt abzuwarten ein Erfolg für die
internationalen Ermittler ist es sicher
die Aktivitäten der Mafia in Deutschland
darüber wollen wir mit einer
ausgewiesenen Expertin sprechen mit Zora
Hauser sie ist Soziologin an der Oxford
Universität und hat über die Aktivitäten
der kalabrischen Mafia promoviert guten
Abend Frau Hauser
guten Abend es heißt das sind keinem
anderen europäischen Land außerhalb
Italiens die Mafia so stark vertreten
ist wie in Deutschland also die
kalabrische Mafia woran liegt das was
gibt es dafür verursachen
ja es ist schon tatsächlich der Fall
dass Deutschland ein sehr strategisches
Land ist für den dranggitter auf der
anderen Seite wissen wir ja dass viele
Kalabrien aus Süditalien im aus
Kalabrien nach Deutschland gekommen sind
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg war das der
Fall aber wir müssen auch darauf
natürlich hinweisen dass nicht alle
Kalabrien mafiuse sind also diese
Präsenz von Menschen aus Süditalien
Menschen aus Kalabrien alleine einfach
nicht reicht damit das Phänomen zu
erklären ist was sie haben in
Deutschland sind Bedingungen die es
dieser Organisation ermöglichen
erfolgreich zu sein und diese
Bedingungen muss man bekämpfen ich
spreche hier ganz klar von Bedingungen
die zum Beispiel es leicht machen oder
zumindest relativ leicht machen Geld zu
waschen in Deutschland für das ist
Deutschland schon europaweit bekannt
aber eben auch dass der Kampf gegen den
dran getan und gegen italienische Mafia
Organisation halt einfach nicht eine
politische Priorität ist und gab es ja
heute diese Razzien europaweit und das
schien noch recht beeindruckend zu sein
wie schätzen Sie das ein
ich glaube schon dass das ein Erfolg ist
das ist sicherlich ein Erfolg der
internationale Kooperation aber es ist
ja halt auch nur einen Schlag und einen
Schlag alleine kann natürlich ganz
alleine nicht die Mafia besiegen und
nicht auch der Kokain schmuggeln nach
Europa einfach aufhalten also in diesem
Sinne brauchen wir halt einfach eine
nachhaltige Strategie die organisierte
Kriminalität allgemein bekämpft und
einen Schlag alleine kann das halt
einfach nicht hinkriegen also sie denken
dabei dann auch an so Themen wie wie
leicht ist in Deutschland ist mit
Bargeld Dinge zu erwerben und damit Geld
zu waschen
ganz genau also es gibt unterschiedliche
Bedingungen und die in unterschiedliche
Ländern dann auch wichtig sind in
Deutschland geht es im wesentliche um
Geldwäsche es ist Geldwäsche die es
nicht nur erlaubt dieser Organisation
ganz sagen wir konkret Geld zu waschen
das ist natürlich sehr wichtig aber das
erlaubt dieser Organisation auch die
legale Wirtschaft wirklich zu
infiltrieren und das ist dann einfach
nur der erste Punkt wo man dann auch zum
Beispiel Verbindungen zur
politikverknüpfen kann wo man sich in
die Gesellschaft allgemein integriert
und indem man das tut sich eben in die
Gesellschaft integriert in die
Wirtschaft integriert man auch unter dem
Radar der Polizei der Behörden und der
Politik bleibt und das ist genau die
Besonderheiten dran in Deutschland ist
das auch ein Grund dafür dass die Karl
lagerische Mafia in Deutschland eher in
kleineren Städten und eher in der
Provinz aktiv ist
ja das hat genau damit zu tun es gibt
unterschiedliche Studien
wissenschaftliche Studien die schon
darauf hingewiesen haben dass Mafia
Organisationen allgemein mehr
erfolgreich sind in Kleinstädter oder in
kleindörfer das ist sicherlich der Fall
in Deutschland man muss sich das halt so
vorstellen wenn man ein erfolgreicher
Gastwirt ist zum Beispiel in Berlin ich
spreche natürlich von Gastwirte die
Kontakte zu einem dran gedauert zum
Mafia haben dann kommt man nicht ganz
sofort ein Termin mit dem Bürgermeister
aber wenn man in eine Kleinstadt eine
erfolgreiche Gastwirt ist dann ist es
halt einfach einfacher an die Politik
nahezukommen und genau aus diesem Grund
ist die Mafia mehr erfolgreich und
zumindest relativ erfolgreicher in
Kleinstädten das sehen wir halt diese
Präsenz sehr stark interessante Einblick
einer Mafia Expertin Frau Hauser danke
Ihnen
vielen Dank
im Bundestagswahlkampf hatte Olaf Scholz
für sicher noch als der klimakanzler
geworden gut damals konnte er natürlich
noch nicht wissen dass er bald sogar
wieder Kohlekraftwerk Hans laufen
bringen muss um russisches Gast zu
ersetzen aber der ukrainekrieg allein
ist für klimaschutzexperten keine
ausreichende Erklärung dafür warum
Deutschland bei den selbstgesetzten
Zielen so hinterher hängt warum Vorgaben
aufgeweicht werden und Maßnahmen die
andere Länder längst umsetzen bei uns zu
politischen Graben kämpfen führen beim
Petersberger klimadialog einer jährlich
tagenden internationalen Konferenz
wollte Scholz heute aber zumindest nicht
mit leeren Händen da stehen meine hisa
und Elisa Miebach
als Olaf Scholz zur Konferenzen ins
Auswärtige Amt hinzustößt ist eins schon
klar das Paar dass ihn hier begrüßt ist
sich nicht ganz grün der
Industrieminister der Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate der die nächste
Weltklimakonferenz leiten wird und
Annalena bärbock die klare Ziele hat
dass wir raus müssen aus den fossilen
Energien dass wir unsere Emissionen
deutlich runterbringen müssen es geht
nicht mehr um Visionen sondern es geht
endlich darum zu liefern nur versteht
der Minister der daheim auch den
staatlichen Ölkonzern leitet
unterliefern etwas ganz anderes
die Zukunft beinhaltet alle
Energiequellen und das Thema war und ist
das Ende der Emissionen
nochmal das Ende der Emissionen
er meint damit nicht das Ende von Kohle
Öl und Gas das entstehende CO2 soll
aufgefangen werden wie in Grundlage in
Island marktreif sind solche
Technologien noch nicht dafür teuer und
energientensiv die Emirate wollen
weltweit Vorreiter bei dieser Technik
werden das ist ein Land was überhaupt
nicht im Ambitionen hat aus ölunggas
auszusteigen sondern möglichst lange
noch davon zu verdienen und das dann so
gut wie es geht irgendwie mit
Klimaschutz zusammenzubringen aber so
werden wir ambitionierte Klimaziele die
wir brauchen als überlebensziele für die
nächste Generation nicht erreichen denn
es geht immer noch um das 1,5 Grad Ziel
so groß die Gräben beim fossilen
Ausstieg bei einem Ziel Rücken alle mehr
zusammen dem weltweiten Ausbau für
erneuerbare Energie bärburg würde das
gerne bei der nächsten Konferenz
festlegen ihr Kollege aus den Emiraten
spricht von einer Verdreifachung bis
2030 das tut doch Olaf Scholz so würden
wir ein deutliches Signal an die real
und die Finanzwirtschaft senden wohin
die Reise geht das bedeutet täglich vier
bis fünf Windkraft Werke an Land zu
bauen und 43 Fußballfelder
Photovoltaikanlagen wohlgemerkt pro Tag
große Worte doch in Deutschland sieht
die Realität noch anders aus
Deutschland investiert weiterhin in den
Ausbau fossiler Infrastruktur zum
Beispiel in LNG Terminals das sind
Investitionen in die falsche Richtung
wir müssen als Deutschland national und
international komplett auf erneuerbare
setzen du weißt Minister hat im Dezember
eine Aufgabe einen Kompromiss zu finden
die Konflikte sind hier in Berlin
glasklar geworden
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
offenbar vor Deutschland zu besuchen
damit geht es jetzt bei dir in den
Nachrichten weiter Gundula ja das hat
eine Sprecherin der Berliner Polizei
berichtet möglicherweise also wird der
ukrainische Präsident selenski am 13 Mai
nach Berlin reisen aus
Sicherheitsgründen werden solche
Reisepläne eigentlich geheim gehalten
allerdings gab die Berliner Polizei
überraschend bekannt sie treffe alle
Vorkehrungen für einen solchen Besuch
zum Internationalen Tag der
Pressefreiheit hat die Organisation
Reporter ohne Grenzen zunehmende
Angriffe auf Journalisten auch in
Deutschland dokumentiert mehr als 100
Attacken im vergangenen Jahr Deutschland
verschlechtert sich damit in der
Rangliste von Platz 16 auf Platz 21
in Belarus ist ein Journalist zu 8
Jahren Straflager verurteilt worden
protestewitz war bei einer erzwungenen
Flugzeuglandung festgenommen worden dem
Oppositionellen wird vorgeworfen die
Massenproteste gegen Staatschef
Lukaschenko unterstützt zu haben
bundeswirtschaftsministerweg steht
weiterhin unter Druck wegen persönlicher
Verpflichtungen in seinem Ministerium
bei der Besetzung der Geschäftsführung
der bundeseigenen Energieagentur die
Generalsekretäre von CDU und CSU fordern
die Entlassung von habex Energie
Staatssekretär reichen der persönliche
Verbindungen bei der Besetzung außer
Acht gelassen hatte im Ministerium sowie
in der Betroffenen Behörde wird über ein
neues Verfahren zur Besetzung des
Postens beraten das Bundeskabinett hat
die Pläne von Verkehrsminister Wissen zu
Beschleunigung vordringlicher
Verkehrsprojekte gebilligt eine Liste
der betroffenen Projekte enthält der
Gesetzentwurf allerdings nicht alle
Bundesländer sollen zugestimmt haben mit
einigen müssen aber noch einzelne
Projekte konkretisiert werden
außerdem hat das Kabinett das Mandat für
den Bundeswehreinsatz im
westafrikanischen Mali verlängert ein
letztes Mal bis Ende Mai 2024 damit
sollen die rund 1100 verbliebenen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten nach und nach
abgezogen werden seit Mitte 2013 ist
Deutschland an der UN-Mission minusma
zur Stabilisierung Marlies beteiligt
in der serbischen Hauptstadt Belgrad hat
ein Jugendlicher an seiner Schule acht
Kinder und einen Wachmann erschossen
sechs weitere Schüler sowie eine
Lehrkraft wurden verletzt der
mutmaßliche Täter ein 13-Jähriger wurde
auf dem Schulhof festgenommen unter
anderem er selbst habe die Polizei
gerufen so die Behörden nach ersten
hinweisen soll er die Tat einen Monat
lang geplant haben warum ist noch unklar
die Schusswaffe gehörte seinem Vater
Vorsprung durch Technik der bekannte
Werbeslogan von Audi bekam durch den
dieselskandal ja etwas ziemlich
mokkantes Vorsprung durch Trickserei war
es was Audi und VW machten und damit am
Ende sich selbst einen Schaden von mehr
als 30 Milliarden Euro zu fügten an
Strafe und Schadenersatzzahlungen und
für die verantwortlichen Manager bis
dahin Stars der deutschen Wirtschaft
folgte ein tiefer Fall der einige bis
ins Gefängnis führte ex-audi-chef
Stadler hat nun heute einen Geständnis
angekündigt siebeneinhalb Jahre nachdem
der Skandal bei VW ans Tageslicht kam
und Audi dann trotzdem noch munter so
weiter machte
Christian
seinen Diesel fährt hartmut-bäumer schon
lange nicht mehr über die Entschädigung
von bislang 20.000 Euro streitet sich
der ehemalige Richter aber immer noch
mit Audi die Unterlagen von 2008 das mit
seinem Neuwagen alles in Ordnung sei hat
er natürlich noch Herr Stadler hat
selbst unterschrieben er garantiert das
alle rechtlichen Normen der EU
eingehalten sind genau das ist nicht der
Fall es ist eine schlichte Lüge und es
kann nicht sein dass zum Beispiel ein
kleiner Ladendieb sofort bestraft wird
und jemand der ganz großen Ding betrügt
einfach frei weiter rumläuft die
Vorwürfe hat Rupert Stadler immer wieder
bestritten als Audi Konzernchef soll er
den Verkauf manipulierter
Dieselfahrzeuge damals zugelassen eben
nicht aktiv gestoppt haben nun ist klar
Stadler wird ein Geständnis ablegen im
Gegenzug hat das Landgericht dem
Angeklagten zugesagt eine Strafe im
Bereich zwischen eineinhalb und zwei
Jahren auf Aktivierung zu verhängen und
auch die Auflage die da Angeklagte zu
zahlen hat nämlich 1,1 Millionen Euro
Bewegung in den Prozess kam durch
sogenannte rechtsgespräche
Staatsanwaltschaft Richter und
Verteidiger hatten zuletzt hinter
verschlossenen Türen Geständnisse und
Strafmaß verhandelt man könnte auch
sagen gedealt für die deutsche Justiz
ist es ein weiteres Kapitel im
dieselskandal eine abschalteinrichtung
sorgt damals auch in Audi Modellen dafür
dass sie auf dem Prüfstand weniger
Schadstoffe ausstoßen als im
Straßenverkehr
derweil baut Stadler als audi-Chef die
Premiummarke weiter aus der Gewinn
steigt wie auch bei Mutterkonzern VW der
Volkswagen-Konzern der war damals auf
dem Sprung der weltgrößte
Automobilhersteller zu werfen und dieses
Ziel wollte man unbedingt erreichen
diesen Ziel hat es sich alles
unterzuordnen und das hat dazu geführt
dass Ingenieure teilweise einfach Regeln
übertreten mussten um beispielsweise die
Abgasvorschriften einzuhalten
2015 dann muss auch Audi zugeben Motoren
manipuliert zu haben Schaden über 3
Milliarden Euro es folgt der tiefe Fall
des Rupert Stadler und ein Sinneswandel
in der deutschen autowirtschaft sagte
Experte die Aufsichtsräte die nehmen
ihre Kontrollfunktion wesentlich ernster
noch als das vielleicht vor 20 Jahren
der Fall war wir sehen auch dass die
Vorstände stärker auf Regelkonformität
ihres Handelns eigentlich ausgerichtet
sind also der Bewusstseinswandel der hat
stattgefunden Mitte Mai will sich
Stadler dann genauer äußern das ist eben
Teil des Deals
und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal weiter
mit dem Blick auf die Finanzmärkte
die US-Notenbank hat vor zwei Stunden
eine weitere leichte Zinserhöhung
beschlossen wie erwartet hob die Fett
den Leitzins um 0,25% Punkte an auf die
Zinsspanne 5 bis 5,25% weil reale die
Finanzmärkte haben damit in etwa
gerechnet wie sehen denn jetzt die
Reaktionen aus die großen amerikanischen
Aktienindizes leichte - die Finanzmärkte
sind also ziemlich cool geblieben
tatsächlich weil die Zinserhöhung
genauso erwartet worden war für die
amerikanische Notenbank war die
Entscheidung dennoch ein Drahtseilakt
die Inflation in den USA ist ja
hartnäckig hoch nach dem Lehrbuch müssen
da die Zinsen rauf andererseits ist
Anfang der Woche wieder eine
Regionalbank zusammengebrochen und der
ganze Sektor unter Druck was er für eine
Zinspause gesprochen hätte das größere
Risiko aber scheint die Fett bei der
hohen Inflation zu fahren ja eine
Nachfrage zu der in den USA schwelenden
Bankenkrise
hat sich die Fett dazu geäußert ja hat
sie
fettchef Paul hat sich dazu geäußert er
beschwichtigt er sagt das amerikanische
Bankensystem sei gesund und
widerstandsfähig man wolle auch an den
Regeln und dann aufsichtspraktiken für
Banken arbeiten damit sich solche
Ereignisse nicht wiederholen aber er hat
auch klar gemacht die amerikanische
Notenbank wolle wachsam bleiben und
gegebenenfalls reagieren und eine
Zinspause im Juni die ist damit
wahrscheinlicher geworden morgen ist
aber erstmal die Europäische Zentralbank
mit ihrer Zinsentscheidung dran vielen
Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
die Gewerkschaft wäre die hat zu neuen
Warnstreiks im öffentlichen Nahverkehr
aufgerufen morgen muss in
Schleswig-Holstein Niedersachsen
Nordrhein-Westfalen Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg mit Ausfällen und
Verspätungen gerechnet werden werde geht
es um ein besseres Angebot für rund 5000
Beschäftigte von Betrieben mit Eisenbahn
Tarifvertrag
in der italienischen Region Emilia
Romania ist es nach heftigen
Niederschlägen zu schweren
Überschwemmungen und Erdrutschen
gekommen mindestens zwei Menschen
verloren ihr Leben hunderte mussten ihre
Häuser verlassen
sinnflutartige Regenfälle hatten dazu
geführt dass Flüsse über die Ufer traten
ganze landwirtschaftsgebiete sind
verwüstet die Böden können nach Monaten
der Trockenheit die Wassermassen nicht
aufnehmen
zähle noch die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten ohne Gewähr 14 15 16
37 42 47 Superzahl 1 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de und im
zdf-
Journal weiter Antje Pieper berichtet
aus der Türkei wo ihr nächste Woche
Präsidentschaftswahlen anstehen und um
00:30 Uhr mit unserem heute journal
Update auf Wiedersehen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen bevor wir gleich aufs Wetter
bei uns schauen ein kurzer Blick auf die
aktuelle Situation der Meere die
Oberflächentemperatur der Meere ist seit
März 2023 zu hoch wie nie zuvor aktuell
liegt der Durchschnitt bei fast 21 Grad
Ozeane sind ein wichtiger Kühler in
unserem Klimasystem sie haben seit den
70er Jahren rund 90% der Wärmeenergie
aufgenommen die vom Menschen verursacht
wurde aber je mehr sich die Luft erwärmt
desto mehr heizen sich auch die Ozeane
auf und das hat Folgen für eine andere
wichtige Aufgabe mehrere entziehen der
Atmosphäre riesige Mengen Kohlendioxid
aber Gase lösen sich in warmen
Flüssigkeiten schlechter als enthalten
dadurch nimmt die Pufferwirkung der
Meere ab
und die Wassertemperaturen vor allem die
Oberflächentemperatur der Meere die
wirkt besonders auf Stürme wir schauen
jetzt erst einmal aufs Wetter und da
haben wir es mit einer sternenklaren
nachzutun es wird tatsächlich noch mal
eisig im Norden Deutschlands bis minus
ein Grad geht's runter im Südwesten
deutlich milder bei plus 7 Grad morgen
haben wir es dann mit viel Sonnenschein
zu tun einzig ganz im Norden sind mal
dichtere Wolken dabei und das wirkt
natürlich auf den UV-Index der ist bei 6
bis 7 angesiedelt das bedeutet der Wert
ist recht hoch schützen Sie sich vor der
Sonne wenn sie längere Zeit draußen sind
Temperaturen dazu 13 bis 14 Grad entlang
der Küsten und mit 25 Grad ein Sommertag
im Südwesten Schauer und Gewitter
erwarten uns dann ab Freitag vor allem
Unwetter artig können Sie dann sein bei
11 bis 23 Grad ein schönen Abend